so hello everyone and today I'm going to
discuss innovation in recommender
systems and - first let's discuss what
innovation means its innovations means
filling the gap between research
prototype and and production and since I
just finished my PhD I have seen a fresh
overview of all the knives machine
learning algorithm that are developed by
PhD students and professor at the
University but sadly just a few manage
to get into to be implemented in a
larger scale scenario in in in the
industries and the key for my opinion
and I will be glad to hear yours at the
end of my talk the key for innovation is
reference implementation so to make for
the community code available in a way
that you can assess it with your own use
case so basically I'm going to discuss
what are the Python libraries available
and in my opinion what are the the weak
points and what we would need to fill
the gap between research and innovation
and in my opinion the current state
especially a new tip I have to admit a
new to the Python community I started to
program in Python and in
let's say January and February and
previously I was working with with Java
and I've seen that actually the the
library at the moment are not at the
state that would foster innovation in my
opinion so I'm the the talk is
structured as follows
I will first say briefly for those of
you that not were not here in the
previous talk what our recommender
system and present collaborative
filtering as a solution and pointing out
what are a major outcome of research of
the last two years mainly and then I
will discuss what are available
libraries so and what kind of algorithm
are there and is pointing out pros and
cons using one or the other libraries so
that we can conclude and discuss as I
said what's missing so I've here two
examples of recommender system I think
the last example does need to be
introduced everyone is familiar with and
with Amazon and the other one is our New
Yorker app and this is a classic case
where you want to use a recommender
system so basically you you want to to
show to recommend to your user items
he/she might like and in order to do so
you profit from his history in your
system and the history of previous users
and but there are really different ways
to do that and so this is what I'm going
to discuss now so first of all I will
focus on
a collaborative filtering and as I said
it aims at predicting what user will
like based on similarities to two other
user and this is opposed to contact
based filtering where you need a lot of
feature engineering and domain knowledge
to to produce our prediction whereas
here whereas here we just profit from a
lot of data so we want a lot of tuples
of user items and their opinion about
those items it's it's really interesting
because it's a personalized prediction
so that those kind of algorithm in a
cheap way a personalized model for each
user and each item and then there is its
called latent modeling so you produce
latent feature which don't have a
physical meaning but they're able
somehow to reconstruct what the user
state what's the user taste in terms of
your a lot of the items you want to
recommend so there as it was already
discussed in the previous talk
collaborative filtering has an
recommendation problem has specific
challenges which are data sparsity
because of course user just created a
few items and you have scalability in a
sense that you have a lot of most of the
time you have a lot of data that you
need to process in a short amount of
time and you have a cold start and again
we've seen that and it it happens when
you have just a few interaction of your
user or an item is new and you don't
know exactly how people what people
think of this item for instance and and
then there is a problem of static
modeling so what static modeling means
is that you have a fix
what you when you train your model you
create a snapshot of situation however
the taste of the user and the popularity
of the item evolves over time and this
also influences the the rating the user
is going to give to the item if it's
going to be higher or lower and for this
reason new algorithm in the developed to
solve this for issues we will see how
and then of course there are also
application challenges so that people
don't really express their opinion they
tend to give neutral opinion which it's
not quite helpful and then of course if
an item is popular you don't want to
downgrade because people tend to
homogenize their opinion to those of
others so the most I think most love
algorithm Atrix authorization and so you
can to understand this it's a classic
example for those that were not here in
the last talk and so you have you can
imagine it as a table you have in a
column you have the different movies and
in the in the rows are different users
and they gave some I gave some some
ratings just for a part of of the
available movies and you want to by
decomposing this this this matrix you
learn the latent variable and you really
factorizing the matrices you can
actually predict those missing items and
this algorithm pretty often used because
it solves to my major points so the data
sparsity which is a key problem of
recommender system data sets and
and the big data problem a sense that
you can they're quite fast also if you
if you use stochastic gradient decent to
solve them they're really fast and
that's a good thing but and then another
important thing to know is then that you
can use metric factorization to
formalize the recommender system in
completely different ways so we have
seen the amazon problem would be
predicting the stars the user would give
to to an object then we have in case of
The New Yorker case you want to predict
if the user will like with pressing on
the on the heart if you will like the
item or not but you can formalize it
also as a rating or ranking problem so
you maybe you don't just want to predict
how many stars is user will give but you
maybe prefer to to predict what's the
best set of items to show to the user in
a first page and the same you can do for
the in implicit feedback case so you
want to predict based on the likes of
the user what are the best for in this
case four items to show to the user to
the same page and also in what order to
to present them and this is called
ranking and there are during the year
different methods have been developed
for for ranking if you consider the
point-wise ranking it is a very same
thing as rating nothing let's say
nothing special that you want to predict
a score for one candidate then there is
pairwise ranking for those of you that
will hear in the previous talk that's
what is used by the VP are the BPR
algorithm
it's the relative position of of two
candidates and then we have the list
wise ranking which is actually the
intrinsic ranking problem so you want in
ranking you want to predict actually all
an order an order of items and so this
is actually some pretty already
historically order so people want
research went from Pontoise
ranking to least twice ranking and then
there have been also other extension
Nets of so main problem as a cold start
problem for and so what you do if you
have no idea about the new items or or
new or new new user and as I said the
static modeling and so the key to solve
this two issues is integrating new
feature and and this what possible
features are we have seen it in a
previous talk already also item and user
characteristics so any kind of
information but one real hot hot topic
in research in recommender system has
been to try to integrate friendships or
trust of user by integrating recommender
system algorithmic vendor system data
sorry
with Twitter and Facebook information
and trying to model the friendship of of
the users because anyway we know that
wish to some sort of degree we share our
tastes with friends and or with people
we follow on Twitter so if we follow
Madonna there is highly likely that we
like her music
so people were trying to get any kind of
information in to to ameliorate the
magic utilization prediction and this
especially becomes important if you have
a cold start problem there have been
research that shows that actually as
soon as you have a lot of data site
information plays a different role minor
role however it's common that in the
real data set there are a lot of user
with a very short history so this work
has been has become quite crucial so
probably some of you knows this
extension so I think that actually there
are many others just point to of the
most famous one it was a fat one is
factorization machine by any chance it
was mentioned before I'm happy to hear
that and so basically it has been it's a
model that was mainly developed to
integrate site information into the
matrix authorization algorithmic really
was time aware matrix factorization this
work was first introduced by Corrin who
is also the person who invented the
matrix authorization algorithm I opinion
the main hot topics in recommender
system at the moment so exchange matter
exploitation extensions and so the
question is now what what is already
there available in in Python that we can
we can use to foster innovation and so
from a machine learning library we
expect that it helped us with the
pre-processing so there are specific
analysis that are conducted when you
work with recommender system that are
really familiar to people that work in
the area and so we expect that there is
some support in that analogy so like
competing the sparsity of a data set we
we would like to to have some support in
experimental settings like dividing for
instance dividing the users in
cold-start user not cold-start user
would be one of those to assess what's
the error on Kolstad user and on normal
users then of course we would like to
have basic and more advanced algorithmic
order time of advances but actually it's
quite useful to have also very simple
methods to see how much the the matrix
authorization is helping and it is good
to quantify because if your metrics
authorization is performing with worse
than global average why should i
implement this big big method and why
why so and yes so basically all the
things we will see we would like
something about coarser we want context
awareness and maybe we want to prefer
ranking and and in a library would like
also to its to be easy to install
because of course I want to be sure that
first of all that what I have is working
before I apply it black box to my use
case this is my opinion really important
and then we would like also to have a
tool that I start to use learn it and
then meanwhile I get feedback from the
community and new methods comes in also
that it's
important yeah and so here have a few
libraries that I analyzed so we have
first the surprise library then crab
gender is als magic utilization
implementation of emilybs sparkly lip
and then we have also FM light which
should be a smaller implementation of
the factorization machine developed by
Randall and yeah I'm not have it here in
a slide so you have it for your records
but I'm not going to discuss scrub
because it has the impression that it's
that in a sense that it's not maintained
anymore if you say otherwise I will
happy to discuss it later so mainly the
libraries of our FM alight they cover
also the 2.7 Python version and there
are some benchmark algorithm implemented
so that you can compare how much each
other ization performs with more simple
or more with simpler or more advanced
algorithm ention SVD k-means and or
random prediction which are the the
algorithm mainly used for comparison to
Mata factorization and I consider the
easiness of news all the free library
had a nice walkthrough tutorial
unfortunately there was not much
discussion about the cold-start
that it's a little bit of pity and
especially for people that are starting
to work in in the area a discussion
would be
would be nice to have and unfortunately
about ranking this freely only cover the
pairwise loss and as I said leastways
not lost is quite established in the
research so it's a pity that it's not
implemented and SM light is the only one
that provides context context awareness
and parallelization is implemented by
the libraries in in different ways part
I believe of course uses spark where as
FM light which uses openmp and this sea
bass and so and both all the libraries
are maintained and as it's also possible
to see from the github statistics so we
are confident that they we will get some
feedback if someone writes under github
forums and yeah so I try to summarize my
opinion why pros and cons so first of
all none of the libraries I've shown you
in my opinion is sufficient to have a
wide variety of algorithms to test and
however you could have according to what
you want to do you can have you have
some choice of some choice of algorithm
Flamel
so for instance light factorization
machine it has the process it implements
already some advances so you have the
context you have the fertilization you
have your ranking however from the
context implementations so as far as I
understood you need to implement it
yourself so you need to compose the
single
blocks and anyway it implements one way
to solve most of the time one way to
solve the problem and it's abased and it
is one thing of BPR it's based on
implicit feedback so if you have ratings
then you you would need to again to
implement a workaround they have they
suggest some workaround or on the
website but anyway you need to sit there
and and work with tool a bit so one
would think since Emily bits is
integrated with with spark that it's
more reliable and then you can use all
the spark libraries to with the prefer
the pre-processing which is nice but it
implements only ALS optimized for
parallelization which is a good thing
but anyway it's just one algorithm and
and then surprise
yeah it's unfortunately it has no
parallelization and and context
integration which is a little bit sad
I liked of this library I liked the
selection of algorithm that they did for
initial analysis and and you see that
they want to from from their page they
want to integrate to to get new you know
new user a new developer in in a group
so you see that they put some effort to
explain you how to use this library in
for you for your use case which i think
is really positive and this is what an
open source library should shoot to so
in when I first submitted the tall super
data I was also said I was going to
discuss the API of the library
however it's not so interesting you've
seen in the previous talk the light of M
API which is a pretty simple so mainly
what one needs to learn is so first how
you read the data so putting the data in
the format that the library can can
process
and then you need to create the model by
calling the train train or fit method
and then test your your algorithm
basically all the API is all of all the
previously introduced libraries work
this way so it's not so interesting and
are not large enough to discuss other
aspects in my opinion and so one so that
the real issues issue in my opinion is
that the community in working on Python
recommenders is quite small so if you
have a look at this free which should be
free of the most use libraries so Sagat
learn tons of flow and Pilar Pilar -
there have quite a lot of comments and
contributors but if we look at the the
free of the the libraries I've analyzed
we have two degree two orders of
magnitude less a number of of commits
and
contributors so it seems that the
recommender system community is working
elsewhere and so what we are missing is
as already said a complete
state-of-the-art reference
implementation from the basic algorithm
most advanced 2015 at least methods and
just to give you an idea there is I
found I knew others but I found recently
this lip break it's a Java library and
yeah actually for matrix factorization
and all more or less these are things
I've shown you they implemented 53
different implementation and algorithm I
dia so of what can and they have nice
selections and it's really algorithmic
are from 2015 and 16
whereas in in the US and the other
libraries we have seen we had just a few
reference implementation for some of the
problems matrix authorization problems
that I've presented you so so again
repeating in conclusion so we don't have
sufficient reference implementations in
in Python but innovation requires those
reference in implementations so my
opinion my hope is that in the future
since the Python community is growing
that we are going to have a stronger
collaboration on open source libraries
in Python
Thank You Carlotta I feel like you added
quite a lot to the conversation that was
started in the last talk so now we have
the 20 of time for questions please
raise your hand and then Johanna is
going to bring the microphone to you
hello hi so my question is you're
working for The New Yorker and the
fashion industry and you're talking
about cold starts so how do you deal
with like in this new season when you
come out with a new line of clothing
maybe the managers want you to promote
those who recommend these items when you
don't have a much data on them yeah so
this is one also for our question and at
the moment so the common way to start
would be to work on first on of course
on basic items we have items that are
repeated over over over a season and
then from that we could integrate
information coming from the social media
to predict trying to recommend things
for for the next season so this could be
a way to do that but it's quite a
difficult topic at the moment and so one
suggestion
my question was for example if we're
thinking for example and self for
example of a storm strike that blood
product that for example a software
product that has certain common use
cases and what you're trying to maximize
is the final result for example of the
person using the software you wouldn't
for example suggest actions that are
necessarily more frequent but those that
result in better results so to speak so
my question is is there any standard
procedure for these kind of things for
example a certain program that you feed
a certain input into it you try to have
a certain output the user does certain
steps and you're trying to maximize the
that certain output since they're like
several steps of process of processing
is there any systematic way of
suggesting you want to you want to
optimize the sequence a sequence of
actions exactly yeah so in in my my PhD
I work in optimizing sequence of tasks
for for per user and the way to do that
would be to combine them met in this
case you want to use it of course one
can magics authorization recommender
with an optimization policy so you try
to given the prediction of the algorithm
to find what's the best action given a
given a score this would be a way to to
do that otherwise you you need actually
to go if you want to read in finder
series correctly then you want one maybe
to use other sequence optimizing
algorithm but we are not in
collaborative filtering anymore
and so you mentioned that light FM
supports privatization my question is
does it support paralyzation across
different nodes in a cluster or across
different GPUs or is in a single machine
I know as far as understood it it
support it supports it in a cluster but
you have the possibility to switch it
off if you want to use it locally okay
and how that would work I mean does it
split the matrices and then optimize
them separately and then joins the I
haven't gone in this much detail
actually I it's so they're using a
stochastic gradient decent then probably
they could optimize the some grid search
training or if they use a LS they could
divide the two steps of optimization
between the item and user features but
you need to go into the details and they
use Python as a wrapper so you need to
be comfortable with see a to see it how
it works okay thanks
hi do you consider graph based
approaches for recommendations yes so I
think it would be another additional
library there is grass lab they have
recommendation and so if you want to use
graphs and with matrix fertilization
this would be awaited a way to or one
thing to to explore I've also read that
there is a spark version so they have
also a graph library that you could
integrate with Emma lib but which one
of the bowls to use and you need
according to what I've read you need to
you need to see really what's your use
case but you have this two option Emily
and GraphLab but you don't consider that
options in production if you have brass
I mean why not try you start first of
course you start with the simple things
and then you you you would add on so
thanks any other questions so there have
been a lot of clever questions so I'll
ask a dumb one now being what one
questions I had was an extremely naive
approach if I'm thinking about this
would be to calc if I want to predict
the process what is the product that I
should show then to calculate the
probability of the person clicking it
for each of the lots of products that I
have and then just choose the one that
is the maximum argument that's kind of
super naive and when is this kind of
approach acceptable if ever and why is
it kind of a bad idea what what is it
the question is kind of when is this
approach really naive of just modeling
it calculating the probability of the
person clicking engine well what what
you describe this the metrics
authorization basically so you can model
it enough from a probabilistic
perspective that's a probabilistic
matrix authorization or you can think
about it is in like with with stars and
how many subjects it's the same from
algorithmic perspective is the same and
it's not a bad idea it works pretty well
the problem is when you have started to
think okay I have a cold start I want to
update my model without retraining it so
for long history user and an item's
magic authorization works quite well
thank you
okay we have time for one final question
any up okay so thank you for the
presentation it's a bit of a tangent to
this stuff but I was thinking with the
cold starts if you know a t-shirt and
another color and a certain cut you know
it's similar to other products so you
could use maybe similarities to other
products as initializations or something
in your model I was wondering if this is
where it gets of a tangent have you
looked at or do you know if any people
doing recommendation systems where they
try to incorporate this prior
information in sort of a in the prior
distribution that I mean there are some
Bayesian methods that can or models and
also libraries like ask like Stan if
you've heard of that or there's a new
one called Edward so you can do things
where you where you put your information
that you know intuitively as a human but
you don't have the data you can
incorporate it sort of into the start of
your model to kind of restrict the
parameter search space because a lot of
the problems that you've mentioned in
the presentation before and the things
that we kind of know intuitively is
human so not everyone is going to buy a
Porsche so obviously all the searches
are gonna lead to sales so you can
include this I was wondering if you
thought of this or if you know of anyone
using it know of the specific libraries
you were mentioning no but is sort of so
from what you said at the right at the
beginning and it as I've known for
instance that you could create cluster
of items in more or less intelligent way
so you could profit from you could do
unsupervised clustering you can use deep
learnings that are quite a few methods
to aggregate items and based on their
similarities predict so you would
imagine factorization framework you
would consider those items as if they
would be one and this is quite often
darkness in for solving the Polestar
problem
yeah okay thank you very much excellent
can we give another round of applause
thank you so much Carlotta